الحل والديبلوماسي مره اخرى يحوم حول
الحرب في اوكرانيا هذه المره الكلام ات من
اوكرانيا وليس من موسكو التي كانت المحت
من جهاتها على لسان مسئوليها الى
استعدادها للتفاوض وزير الخارجيه
الاوكرانيه الديمتروكوليبا اشار بتصريح في
بصريح العباره الى ان الحل الديبلوماسي هو
المخرج الحتمي للحرب لكن وفقا المكاسب
المحققه على الميدان
كل حرب تنتهي بطريقه دبلوماسيه ونتيجه
التطورات التي تتم في ساحه المعركه وعلى
طاوله المفاوضات وهي مرتبطه ايضا بما يتم
كسبه في ساحه المعركه وما يتم كسبه ايضا
في المفاوضات
تصريحات تتزمن مع اعلان اوكرانيا عزمها
عقده قمه السلام في حلول الذكرى الاولى
لبدء العمليه العسكريه الروسيه شهر فبراير
القادم وذلك بواسطه من الامم المتحده
وامينها العام انطونيش غير ان روسيا ليست
مدعوه بهذه القمه الا اذا واجه الجرائم
حرب امام محكمه دوليه حسب تاكيدات وزير
الخارجيه الاوكراني هذا هو ابدى الامين
العام للامم المتحده استعداده للتوسطك
الازمه في اوكرانيا فقط بموافقه جميع
الاطراف بما في ذلك روسيا
موسكو وان المحت مرارا عن استعدادها
للتفاوض الا ان العقبه الاساسيه تبقى شروط
التي يضعها كل طرف فردنا على رغبه
اوكرانيا في عقلي قمه السلام قال المتحدث
باسم الكربلاند متر سكوف انه لا امكانيه
لاجراء مفاوضات سلام مع كلاب شروطها مضيفا
ان روسيا لم تتبع ابدا شروط الاخرين بل
تلتزم فقط باهدافها الخاصه والمنطقيه